the goal of this video is to find the
solution set
for the following equation so all of the
x values
and we're dealing with radians that will
satisfy
this equation so i encourage you like
always pause this video and see if you
can work through this on your own before
we work through it together
all right now let's work through it
together now your intuition which would
be correct
might be let's see if we can isolate the
sine of x
over 4 algebraically and the first step
i would do is subtract
11 from both sides and if you do that
you would get 8
sine of x over
4 is equal to 3 just subtracted 11 both
sides
now to isolate the sine i would divide
both sides by 8
and i would get sine of x
over 4 is equal to 3 8.
now before i go further let's think
about whether this is the most
general solution here or whether we're
going to find all of the solution set
here
well we have to remind ourselves let me
actually draw a little bit of a unit
circle here
so that's my x-axis that's my y-axis
then a circle and
if we have some angle theta
right over here so that's theta we know
that the sine of theta is equal to
the y coordinate of where this radius
intersects
the unit circle and we also know that if
we add
an arbitrary number of two pi's here if
we subtract an arbitrary number of two
pi's we go all the way around the unit
circle back to where we began
and so the sine of theta would be the
same so we know that
sine of theta plus any integer
multiple of 2 pi that's going to be
equal to
the sine of theta
and so we can generalize this a little
bit we could instead of just saying sine
of x over 4 is equal to 3
8 we could write that sine of
x over 4 plus any integer multiple of 2
pi
is going to be equal to 3 8 where n is
any integer it could even be a negative
1 a negative 2 or
of course could be 0 1 2 3 so on and so
forth
so is this if we solve now
for x is this going to give us the most
general solution set
well we can also remind ourselves that
if i have
theta here and sine of theta gets there
there's one other point on the unit
circle where i get the same
sign it would be right over here the y
coordinate would be the same
and one way to think about it is if we
start at
pi radians which would be right over
there and we were to subtract
theta we're going to get the same thing
so this angle right over here
you could view as pi minus theta
and you could keep trying it out for any
theta even the theta that put you in the
second quadrant third quadrant or fourth
quadrant
if you do pi minus theta sine of pi
minus theta you're going to get the same
sine value
so we also know that sine of pi
minus theta is equal to sine
of theta and so let me write another
expression
over here so it's not just sine of x
over 4 is equal to 3 8
we could also write that sine
of pi minus x over 4 because x over 4 is
the theta here
sine of pi minus x
over 4 is equal to 3 8. and of course we
can also use the other principle that we
could
add 2 pi or subtract 2 pi from this an
arbitrary number of times
and the sine of that will still be equal
to 3 8. so i could write it like this
sine of pi minus
x over 4 plus an integer multiple of 2
pi
that is going to be equal to 3 8.
and if i solve both of these the
combination of them the union of them
would give me the broadest solution set
so let's do that
so over here let me take the inverse
sine of both sides i get
x over 4 plus 2 pi
n is equal to the inverse sine
of 3 8. now i could subtract 2 pi n from
both sides
i get x over 4 is equal to the inverse
sine of 3 8 minus 2
pi n and if you think about it because n
can be any integer this
sign here in front of the 2 this
negative really doesn't matter it could
even be a positive
and now let's multiply both sides by 4.
we get x
is equal to 4 times the inverse sine
of 3 8 minus
8 pi n and then if i work on
this blue part right over here same idea
take the inverse sine of both sides we
get pi
minus x over 4 plus 2 pi
n is equal to the inverse sine of 3
8 and then let's see i could subtract pi
from both sides and subtract 2 pi n from
both sides so i get negative
x over 4 is equal to the
inverse sine of 3 8
minus pi minus 2 pi
n and i multiply both sides by negative
4 i get
x is equal to negative 4 times the
inverse sine
of 3 8 plus 4 pi
plus 8 pi n
and as i mentioned the union of both of
these give us the entire solution set
to our original equation here